sigamos pensando en distintas formas de
sentar a cierta cantidad de personas en
un número de sillas porque hay digamos
por ejemplo que tenemos seis personas la
persona a la persona ve
d
efe y en este vídeo vamos a ver todas
las formas que hay de acomodar a estas
seis personas en tres lugares el lugar 1
el lugar 2 y el lugar 3 todas las formas
en los que se pueden sentar estas seis
personas entre esos cientos o sea las
permutaciones de seis personas en tres
lugares y esto es simplemente un repaso
de la serie de vídeos anterior pero es
muy útil repasarlo para lo que vamos a
ver en este vídeo entonces cuáles son
las combinaciones de seis personas en
tres lugares pues bueno nos fijamos en
el lugar número uno y cuántas personas
distintas podríamos poner en el lugar
número uno pues podríamos poner seis
personas distintas aunque ya tenemos
seis escenarios distintos donde en cada
escenario tenemos una persona distinta
sentándose en la silla número uno ahora
a cada uno de esos escenarios cuántas
personas podrían sentarse en la silla
número dos pues en todos esos escenarios
ya tenemos que una persona se sentó en
la silla número uno entonces nos quedan
cinco personas que podrían llegar a
sentarse por aquí también lo podemos ver
como que hay seis casos de que personas
se van a sentar en la silla número uno y
cada uno de esos casos se divide en
otros cinco casos en los cuales otra
persona se siente en la silla número 2
entonces en total si nos fijamos en las
dos sillas tenemos 30 casos lo que
tenemos 30 escenarios en los que tenemos
a una persona sentada en el asiento
número 1 y otra persona sentada en el
asiento número 2 y para cada uno de los
30 escenarios cuántas personas podría
sentar en la silla número 3 pues si se
sentaron dos personas todavía te quedan
cuatro personas paradas que podrían
llegar y sentarse en este asiento
entonces para cada uno de los 30
escenarios que tenemos aquí tenemos
cuatro personas que se pueden sentar en
el tercer lugar entonces el número total
de escenarios el número total de formas
de acomodar a seis personas en tres
lugares donde nos importa el orden en el
que se sientan es seis por cinco por
cuatro los cuales 120 son permutaciones
permutaciones
y vale la pena pensar en qué es lo que
cuentan estas permutaciones recuerda
cuando estamos hablando de permutaciones
nos importa mucho quién está sentado en
qué silla ok a b c es una permutación y
luego
y se ve es otra permutación y luego
también tenemos de c a b a c y todas
estas son permutaciones distintas en
todas estas permutaciones tenemos
exactamente a las mismas tres personas
pero sentadas en una silla distinta y
cada una de éstas cuenta como una
permutación distinta aunque hay de estas
120 permutaciones aquí ya tenemos a
cuatro de ellos y también podemos tener
a c a b con las mismas personas ya se ve
si estamos pensando en el mundo de las
permutaciones estas seis cosas que tengo
aquí son seis cosas distintas son seis
permutaciones de las mismas tres
personas pero por supuesto estas 120
permutaciones también toman en cuenta
permutaciones que tienen a otras
personas por ejemplo también tenemos la
permutación efe de c y la permutación f
se ve donde aquí tenemos a la persona a
efe que no había aparecido en estas
permutaciones pero bueno también podemos
tener las permutaciones de f c o d
efe y bueno hay 120 permutaciones no las
voy a escribir todas pero si voy a
escribir otras dos ok entonces podemos
tener aquí a a efe que aunque déjame
poner otra permutación porque se pone
interesante más adelante
entonces queremos a la permutación
efe
y a la permutación ce efe b aunque estas
son 12 de las 120 permutaciones de 6
personas en tres lugares pero qué
pasaría si lo único que nos importará
fuera qué personas están sentadas ok si
no nos importará el orden en el que
sentamos a las personas ni en que si ya
están sentadas en ese otro mundo en el
que sólo nos importará qué personas
están sentadas todas estas permutaciones
de aquí estas 6 permutaciones de aquí
serían exactamente el mismo objeto ok
porque en realidad aquí en estas 12
permutaciones tenemos a las mismas tres
personas y estas otras seis
permutaciones de aquí también serían un
solo objeto okey porque también tenemos
únicamente tres personas sentándose en
las sillas
estas seis permutaciones representan el
mismo conjunto de tres personas
entonces surge la pregunta si tenemos
seis personas y tres lugares pero no nos
importa el orden en el que se acomoden
las personas en los lugares cuántas
formas hay de escoger a tres personas
que vayan a sentarse en las sillas y te
recomiendo que le pongas una pausa y
trates de encontrar la respuesta bueno
pues la pista para encontrar esa
respuesta la tenemos aquí o sea si
tenemos a tres personas y la sentamos en
orden entre sillas lo que nos quedan son
seis permutaciones entonces un conjunto
de tres personas forman seis
permutaciones y al final de cuentas
estas 120 permutaciones podríamos
acomodar las de esta forma y entonces
cada uno de estos bloques representa un
conjunto de tres personas en el que no
nos importa en qué orden se sienten
entonces para encontrar el número de
conjuntos de tres personas lo que
tenemos que hacer es tomar el número
total de permutaciones
a 120 y dividirlo en 36 o sea el número
de formas de acomodar a tres personas en
tres lugares un número de formas
formas de ordenar ordenar
a tres personas
eres zonas que hay 120 permutaciones 120
permutaciones entre el número de formas
de ordenar a tres personas en tres
asientos numerados
6 y eso es igual a 20
estas son cosas distintas por aquí lo
que tenemos es cuántas formas hay de
tomar a seis personas y sentar las en
tres sillas que están ordenadas y por
otro lado por acá lo que tenemos es
cuántas formas hay de que escoger a tres
que van a ser las elegidas para sentarse
en alguna silla sin que nos importe el
orden de las sillas
ok por aquí lo que tenemos son las
combinaciones de seis personas de las
cuales escogemos tres aunque tenemos 20
combinaciones con
acciones y otra vez estas 6
permutaciones que tenemos aquí en
realidad en el mundo de las
combinaciones son simplemente una
combinación la combinación en la que
escogemos a la persona a la persona ve y
la persona hace pero no tenemos ningún
orden fijo para ellos yo escogí a estas
tres personas y no importa el orden en
el que las escogí y por aquí esto que
tenemos aquí es la combinación f b c ok
en las combinaciones no me importa el
orden yo simplemente escogí tres
personas y no las escogí en ningún orden
en particular y entonces estas seis
permutaciones se reducen a una sola
combinación y bueno cuantas
combinaciones seis de seis personas de
las cuales escojo únicamente tres sin
ningún orden pues hay 20 20
combinaciones y este número lo podemos
encontrar dividiendo el número de
permutaciones
de seis personas en tres lugares entre
el número de formas en las que podemos
ordenar a tres personas en tres lugares
en este caso dividiendo entre 6